nous sommes un an et demi après
l'élection présidentielle et les
français ont le droit de se poser des
questions sur leur avenir et ceux qui
sait tous n'ont amélioré
est ce que la dépense publique a été
mieux gérer est-ce que leur pouvoir
d'achat s'est renforcée ou est-ce qu'au
contraire toutes les taxes ont augmenté
est-ce qu'on a traitées les questions
d'insécurité en protégeant nos forces de
l'ordre est-ce que l'immigration massive
a été enrayée et tout simplement est-ce
qu'on a mené la lutte qui est
indispensable contre l'islamisme est
votre sentiment sur toutes ces questions
c'est que ça ne va pas dans la bonne
direction
sur tous ces sujets en moins d'un an et
demi la situation s'est dégradée et le
président de la république qui a rajouté
un mépris par rapport à la situation et
la vie quotidienne des français nous
nous nous employons à construire une
nouvelle droite
nous avons été parmi les premiers à
dénoncer les illusions de ce que portel
président de la république nous l'avons
fait avec une nouvelle génération des
nouveaux visages et en ayant aussi à
coeur à chaque fois de ne pas se
contenter d'opposer mais aussi de
proposer comme nous l'avons fait sur les
taxes en proposant des économies pour
pouvoir rendre l'argent français ainsi
que nous faisons dans les régions que
nous gérons comme nous l'avons fait en
proposant des mesures très précises sur
la sécurité destinées à mieux protéger
nos forces de l'ordre
comme nous l'avons fait sur les
questions d'immigration massive comme
nous l'avons fait sur l'islamisme en
réclamant l'expulsion immédiate
hors du territoire français de tous ceux
qui sont binationaux et qui se rapproche
des réseaux intégristes je suis
convaincu qu'il ya un autre chemin
possible
je suis convaincu que la france n'est
pas condamnée à ses politiques dans
lesquels vous payer sans cesse plus et
ou à l'arrivée on ne voit rien
s'améliorer dans notre pays c'est cette
alternative que nous voulons rendre aux
français
c'est ce choix que nous voulons vous
rendre avec une nouvelle droite